This is not a test.
In recent years, there's been much talk of
American schools having been consumed
by "testing mania." Heck, I've shared
some of these concerns myself.
We especially hear these
concerns raised in comparison to
supposed role models, like Finland. But
how much of an international outlier,
really, is the US when it comes to
emphasis on testing? Turns out, not so much.
A recent OECD analysis shows that
in 2015, 83 percent of US teachers put major
emphasis on classroom tests to monitor
student progress. That sounds like a lot,
but it wasn't much higher than the OECD
average of 77 percent. Meanwhile,
in science, in both 2007 and 2015, US
teachers put less emphasis on tests
than did their OECD counterparts. In other
words, the US was a bit above the international
norm in math and a bit lower in science.
If we think the international community
is a reasonable benchmark,
the data suggests that concerns
about over emphasis on testing
have been somewhat overblown.
Do you think American schools are obsessed
with testing? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.